[Musique]
Véronique prince Jonathan Trudeau Michel
COG bonsoir
bonsoir On va intro de parler de la
chasse au faisan ce soir mais d'abord
d'abord motion du gmpdic a été voté à la
Chambre des communes joues pas entendre
trois extraits aujourd'hui on demande le
retrait de Monsieur Johnson
son nom un peu de sens de l'État un peu
de dignité un peu de respect pour la
démocratie et un peu de respect pour la
sécurité les institutions canadiennes le
Premier ministre doit dire à Monsieur
Johnson d'aller faire autre chose et
donner mandat ou permettre à la chambre
de désigner quelqu'un pour mettre en
place une véritable enquête publique on
a dit depuis le début que la décision
d'avoir une représentation spéciale
c'était une mauvaise décision parce que
on a dit que tu on est toujours dit on a
besoin d'une enquête publique et le
processus de enquête publique pour
rétablir la confiance de notre système
électoral on continue d'avoir cette
position
on avait demandé à Monsieur Pallière de
nous donner des recommandations
suggérées des noms pour le rapporteur
spécial même pour partager un an il n'y
a pas voulu dire ah non il y a pas voulu
non
on sait très bien que Monsieur Paulien
ne veut pas prendre ça au sérieux il
cherche tout simplement des endroits
attaqués sur le dos de notre démocratie
sur le dos de l'ingérance Chine chinoise
bon il reste une motion qui a été votée
je veux je vous fais part de la réponse
ça vient de sortir il y a une demi-heure
de Monsieur de gentil il dit je reste là
en deux mots là il y a plus de lettres
mais je reste il dit j'ai le devoir de
poursuivre ce travail jusqu'à la fin de
mon mandat Michel seoget
ça va où à partir de maintenant
d'abord bien franchement parce que je
suis sidéré je ne croyais pas quelqu'un
comme Monsieur Johnston pourrait dire le
Parlement savez-vous je sais pas si
important que ça et je m'en fous un peu
c'est ça qui dit j'étais nommé par le
gouvernement tout ce qui compte c'est le
gouvernement il y a une majorité de
députés qui pensent que je devrais pas
faire ça puis que je parle qui qui n'ont
pas confiance en moi et je vais rester
quand même parce que sur des questions
de sécurité nationale ça exige un degré
de consensus le gouvernement peut parler
tout seul là-dedans et Monsieur Johnson
là a l'air de dire moi qui peut faire ça
de toute façon l'idée qu'il m'est venue
à l'esprit Patrice dans 2000
l'ordinateur qui allait
tuer tout le monde pour s'occuper de la
mission parce que les humains étaient
pas capable de faire ça
parfait
on fait quoi alors on recommence à zéro
avec un autre quel autre puis qui va
avoir grâce au jeu de la position mais
continuons Jonathan
je partage le sentiment de Michel sur la
réaction de Monsieur Johnston vous savez
moi depuis le début j'ai l'impression
que David Johnston qui a une carrière
impeccable un CV impressionnant personne
ne remettait en doute son sens hérétique
j'avais l'impression qu'il était en
quelque sorte victime d'un tiramis de
Justin Trudeau qui l'avait nommé l'homme
et qu'il mettait forcément dans
l'embarras en acceptant ce poste mais là
on est rendu à plusieurs
occasions où il aurait pu se récuser il
aurait pu céder sa place il aurait pu
recommander ce qui fait consensus
c'est-à-dire une enquête publique il
s'obstine et le même après le désaveu de
la Chambre des communes avec un une
certaine légèreté un certain laxisme
vous savez moi je vais rester je vais
prendre mes continuer à assumer mon rôle
je m'excuse mais malheureusement David
Johnston court maintenant après les les
critiques qui sont tout à fait légitimes
quand on regarde la somme des problèmes
en termes de perception
Véronique moi je trouve que les taux
c'est extrêmement resserré aujourd'hui
c'est sûr qu'on s'y en attendait à
rester prévisible mais le fait que ce
soit officiellement arrivé aujourd'hui
je vois difficilement comment il peut
continuer de s'accrocher parce que
qu'est-ce que ça dit au niveau de sa
légitimité ça crédibilité de son
autorité morale comment va-t-il pouvoir
continuer de faire son travail sans que
le débat tourne toujours autour de sa
personne plutôt que l'ingérence chinoise
en tant que tel puis pendant ce temps-là
le gouvernement est pris là il est comme
dans des sables mouvements et pas
capable d'avancer de faire avancer son
agenda politique et comment avancer
rapidement sous question comment avancer
si tenter qu'il partait demain dit très
bien je vous ai entendu je m'en vais on
fait quoi Michel C
il est possible de faire une enquête
publique même sur des questions de
sécurité nationale avec des documents
qui avaient documents qui pourront pas
être rendus public ça ouvre au moins
faire la pédagogie des menaces sur la
démocratie canadienne alors il faut
faire
un ex juge qui fait consensus
de s'en occuper Jonathan
on fait quoi à partir de maintenant ben
on fait preuve de leadership c'est ce à
quoi on s'attend d'un Premier ministre
en fonction malheureusement c'est une
lacune du côté de Justin Trudeau depuis
longtemps trop souvent on a qu'à passer
au convoi à Ottawa donc effectivement de
dire que ne serait-ce que pour
conserver protéger la confiance des
Canadiens des Canadiennes envers nos
institutions démocratiques mais on va la
faire l'enquête publique qui est à ce
qu'il y a des des documents
effectivement qui soit caviaris sauf que
là les travaux de Monsieur Johnston sont
uniquement voués à l'échec parce que peu
importe s'il poursuit la conduite de ces
travaux là personne va va va les juger
crédible et politiquement ultimement
mais ça va continuer à faire mal ajuster
un truc d'eau très bien Véronique
en fait moi je me demande pourquoi le
gouvernement soumet pas une courte liste
de nom puis un vote aux deux tiers je
veux dire cette procédure-là ça se fait
Québec là pourquoi ça pourrait pas se
faire donc on irait chercher une partie
de l'appui de l'opposition
à suivre Michael c'est bien
officiellement confirmé au Conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui et ça a donné lieu
à une espèce de discussion parce que
Québec Solidaire a attaqué il y a eu des
commentaires sur le privé dans la
production petite centrale et éolienne
alors on écoute ce que ça a donné
aujourd'hui qu'on revient
espionne volonté de privatiser en partie
Hydro-Québec oui ou non on a besoin
d'une réponse à cette question là le
ministre doit clarifier ses propos
d'hier est-ce qu'on s'en va oui ou non
vers une privatisation partielle
d'Hydro-Québec le flou doit être dissipé
rapidement surtout que Monsieur c'est
bien quand même par le passé contribué à
la privatisation de grandes entreprises
journée importante le Conseil des
ministres va choisir le nouveau
président d'Hydro-Québec déjà il y a des
projets qui sont faites par le privé
pensons à tous les projets qui sont
faits par borélix donc on a rien contre
le privé
une valeur incroyable émotive et
financière
on va pas privatiser il est au Québec
Michel parce que les Québécois vont et
René l'évêque va se retourner dans sa
tombe mais il dit elle pose des petites
choses là c'est très bon le privé là
c'est de voir le ministre dire
responsable du drogue dire le privé
toujours mieux que le public
quand par exemple à l'époque du
gouvernement Maroua on avait 19 dans les
petites centrales c'est des choses qui
doivent être dans le domaine public
parce que pourquoi est-ce que
Hydro-Québec s'il y a un contrat
avec profit à des entrepreneurs privés
qui ont un barrage ça a pas de bon sens
et ces choses-là
si tu peux tellement y avoir du copinage
de du patronage dans ces choses-là
que tu as un produit
ça c'est dérangeant beaucoup de monde
puis évidemment
ça fonctionne très bien donc pourquoi il
faut mettre des criminer là-dedans moi
Jonathan
ça fonctionne très bien au Québec et il
y a déjà du privé là-dedans donc est-ce
que la déclaration de Pierrefitte gibbin
était maladroite je le pense j'ai
l'impression qu'il a prit par excès de
franchise je sais pas comment les
enfants au Québec de confiance aussi
parce qu'il y avait eu des bonnes
nouvelles mais on y reviendra on y
reviendra peut-être donc peut-être que
c'était pas habile sauf que moi
sincèrement d'agiter l'épouvantail du
privé puis le dogme de celle de privé
c'est donc un mauvais c'est donc intérim
il y a déjà du privé dans la dans la
production d'énergie au Québec tous les
projets éoliens passent par le privé
vous savez quoi ce qui est bien c'est
que la communauté doit aussi être
impliquée donc des communautés dmrc des
municipalités qui attirent un profit qui
sont impliqués qui crée de l'emploi donc
on parle de quelque chose qui existe pas
moi d'entendre Gabriel ado Dubois dire
est-ce qu'il veut privatiser une partie
d'Hydro-Québec c'est pas de ça dont on
parle on parle des petits projets de
moins de 50 MW ou déjà le privé peut
participer donc il y a rien le niveau
au-delà de la déclaration un peu
malhabile sur l'efficacité du privé
versus l'état
Véronique vous êtes d'accord
moi j'ai pas trouvé ce flou du tout en
fait là où ça a été maladroit c'est de
dire qu'il trouve souvent que privé
meilleur que l'État là mais sinon pour
le reste pour moi c'était assez clair
qui veut pas s'en aller vers là
d'ailleurs je lui ai posé la question
avant dans les dernières semaines au
moins à deux trois reprises puis à
chaque fois il m'avait donné la même
réponse c'est comme ça existe déjà on va
continuer avec qui existe déjà et pour
les gros projets ça va toujours être au
Québec c'est toujours Hydro-Québec qui
va avoir le contrôle mais il a eu un
avertissement un petit avertissement
c'est à dire que c'est émotif
Hydro-Québec alors si l'OSE se mettre le
pied un petit peu plus vers le privé et
là il voit le débat que ça peut
entraîner mais elle est plus vieux se
souviennent aussi un autre temps
l'Hydro-Québec on y pense peut-être pas
le matin en se levant mais lui aussi ça
y est peut-être sentimentale et il a eu
une bonne journée jonat han joue fait
entendre ça va être avec vous mais je
vais vous faire entendre d'abord parce
qu'il a été blanchi par la commissaire
elliptique sur sa partie de chasse au
faisant on n'a pas la photo avec le
chapeau et tout ça on écoute aujourd'hui
parce que ça a donné
est-ce que vous allez changer quoi que
ce soit dans votre façon de procéder la
prochaine fois que vous allez là
a été blanchi ridicule cet accusation là
des libéraux on a le droit on a le droit
sur cette un livre de la chasse moi
j'aime pas ça
la question qu'on posait pas entendu le
soin était pas très bon mais est-ce que
vous allez changer quoi que ce soit dans
votre façon de procéder puis dit
aucunement donc Jonathan victoire pour
le chasseur ou faisant quand même ouais
la réflexion que je me faisais
aujourd'hui en écoutant pierre Fitz
Gabin c'est que vraiment là on va se
souvenir longtemps de ce ministre là qui
est devenu une espèce de personnage
incontournable très particulier c'est
dans 10 ans dans 15 ans dans 20 ans on
va se souvenir du ministre puis ensuite
alors que d'autres ministres pensent et
ne laisse pas nécessairement leur stress
donc cette espèce de désinvolture là on
n'est pas nécessairement surpris sauf
que moi ce que j'ai retenu notamment
durant la période des questions c'est
l'espèce de fanfaronnade de François
Legault qui accusait les parties
d'opposition d'avoir voulu se faire du
capital politique là-dessus de mettre
pierre-feuille
comme un pot oublié que c'était son
sixième rapport de la commissaire à
l'éthique qu'il a été il a fait l'objet
de de reproches d'un blanc dans deux de
ses colonnes donc je resterai un peu
humble sur sur ce je gardais en tête
aussi que la commissaire a quand même
dit que même si elle le blanchissait la
ligne était mince et que des fois la
prudence était de mise disons oui parce
que lui dit chaque vous voulez y aller
encore puis Véronique qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire lui dit soyez prudent mais
bien sûr avec les armes et soyez prudent
de ne pas mêler et qu'est-ce que veut
dire ça veut dire de pas baisser sa
garde parce que moi j'ai remarqué qu'en
2018 quand le gouvernement logo était
tout jeune encore c'est comme c'est à ce
moment-là on voulait beaucoup protéger
l'image perfidique justifier ses actions
expliquer à chaque fois qu'il vient du
monde des affaires donc il connaît
beaucoup de jobs etc etc rappelez-vous
quand il a quitté temporairement le
Conseil des ministres et qu'il est
revenu avec un appui massif du milieu
des affaires c'est comme c'est à partir
du moment là ce sont dit il a une
légitimité et depuis ce temps-là on
assume le personnage pierrefitteben tant
qu'il commet pas d'impair que c'est pas
illégal qui a pas de conflit d'intérêt
la perception du faux ça leur dérange
pas trop non plus mais tant que c'est
correct puis que ça ça remplit les
critères de la commissaire à l'éthique
ben c'est un personnage pour avoir
l'assumer puis on va vivre avec ça c'est
un peu seul
c'est un principe quand même important
c'est qu'il a le droit malgré tout au
ministre tant qu'il est d'avoir une vie
privée aussi
cette histoire-là n'aurait jamais dû
savoir
a des êtres et comme il a été toujours
dans le milieu des affaires ces amis
c'est déjà des milieux d'affaires
mais d'autre part Monsieur Philippe a le
droit d'aller à la place c'est une
activité que moi j'aime beaucoup mais
qui est légal au Québec troisièmement
alors ça va jamais dû se retrouver
devant la commissaire analytique puis
sinon on va dire monsieur
qui pourrait rencontrer quelqu'un qui
connaît qui parlait des affaires du
gouvernement
commercial les extraits Vincent Maricel
y accrochage vincent Marissal et le
ministre du burn écoute rapidement
idéale ce serait d'enlever le projet de
loi 15 mais ça arrive pas alors est-ce
qu'on peut retravailler les structures
qui sont proposées moi je vais être
bonsoir Comme je suis d'habitude je vais
essayer d'améliorer cette affaire là
je penserai par dessus ce commentaire là
parce que je pense que si monsieur
marisan vous député de Rosemont pense à
tout le travail qui a été mis dans la
préparation de ce projet de loi là puis
dire que ce serait mieux de le retirer
au complet je pense qu'il y a un peu un
manque de respect de sa part
bon ça sera pas adopter cette session 6
on le savait déjà Véronique tour de
table là-dessus monsieur Dubé là il y a
son bâton de pèlerin il trouve le chemin
long là oui mais en même temps c'était
prévisible puis le savait très bien que
ça allait pas être si simple puis il en
est pas son premier accrochage avec
Vincent marxa moi je pense que c'est cet
automne ou là ça va commencer à presser
parce qu'il doit l'adopter avant le 31
décembre pour que ça puisse entrer en
vigueur dans les délais qui l'espère
pour l'opposition d'ailleurs c'est que
est-ce qu'une réforme administrative va
donner des résultats concrets d'un
hôpitaux dans les cliniques etc ce qu'on
veut pour avoir un médecin de famille
plus facilement difficile de faire de
faire de prime abord le lien entre de
meilleurs services et une réforme
essentiellement administrative Jonathan
je vais passer outre le fait que Vincent
marisan suggère de jeter aux poubelles
un projet de loi aussi important et
costaud que celui-là comme s'il y avait
rien de bon là-dedans mais
je vais je vais revenir sur le clou je
vais retaper sur le clou de
l'épouvantail du privé encore une fois
le Vincent Marseille disait on doit
mettre un bouclier anti privé ce que les
gens qui nous écoutent moi je pense en
parlant des gens en lisant noter les
spectateurs de plus en plus les gens se
disent si dans le privé il peut y avoir
une quantité de service comme on l'a vu
dans la pandémie qui qui ne favorise pas
le médecine à trois vitesses mais qui
font en sorte qu'il y a des soins dans
le privé à faire rapidement mais
rembourser par l'État il y a des gens
qui disent si ça fonctionne pourquoi on
s'en priverait et là on part après ça
alors que je pense que le c'est un
projet de loi qui assurément perceptible
il y a beaucoup de travail à faire il y
a des négociations à voir mais encore
une fois pourquoi ajouter c'est ajouter
ces épouvantails là comme une espèce de
tradition on espère que un espèce de
dogme ça ient un peu lassant Véronique
je vous donne la parole intermina
qu'est-ce qui reste à adopter le bon
l'aide à mourir ça va ça va passer
qu'est-ce qui reste à faire à Québec
le salaire des élus ça va être celui
qu'on va le plus surveiller évidemment
c'est lui qui va faire jaser dans les
prochains jours sinon il y a aussi des
projets de loi en environnement sur le
fond bleu qui devrait adopter bientôt
mais je pense que vraiment celui qu'on
surveille le plus c'est ça c'est le
salaire des élus pour ce qui est de la
réforme du BIR réforme d'un ville
oubliez ça pour cette session aussi
c'est impossible mathématiquement
possible je fais une semaine qu'on a
fait on fait un panel depuis presque une
semaine on a pas parlé de Bernard
drinville non mais il fait profil bas
cette semaine nous parle pas beaucoup je
trouve très bien merci à vous trois
bonne soirée à très bientôt au revoir
bonne soirée